hello everyone and Welcome to our video
on skills required for any engineer with
the Advent of artificial intelligence
and its Superior abilities to improve
human life the need and demand for
expert AI professional is at an all-time
high this expanding demand has led to a
lot of people applying for AI jobs and
upskilling themselves in the field of AI
but doing this is just like playing a
game but not knowing its rules for
someone to become an air professional
and land a job like an air engineer they
first have to understand the demand from
this role and what the skills are
expected of an AI engineer so if you are
someone who wishes to become an AI
engineer or if you wish to upgrade your
skills in Ai and get promoted as an AI
engineer then make sure you watch this
amazing video till the very end in this
video we will be breaking down in
complete detail each and every skill
that you would need in order to crack an
AI engineer job interview but why should
you consider career in AI
AI is not just a passing Trend it's a
seismic ship that is reshaping our world
and creating new avenues for Innovation
and discovery by embracing a career in
AI you become a part of dynamic field
that thrives on solving complex problems
pushing boundaries and making a profound
impact on society the demand for AI
professional is skyrogating across
industries from Healthcare and finance
to entertainment and transportation
organizations are actively seeking
talented individuals who can harness the
power of AI to drive their business
forward but what is skills does it take
to become an AI engineer how can you
embark on the thrilling Journey we have
answered to all of your questions also
accelerate your career in Ai and ml
without comprehensive postgraduate
program in AI animal machine learning
gain expertise in machine learning deep
learning NLP computer vision and
reinforcement learning you will receive
a prestigious certificate exclusive
aluminum membership and ask me anything
session by IBM with three Capstone
project and 25 plus industry projects
using real data set from Twitter Uber
and many more you will gain practical
experience master classes by Caltech
faculty and IBM expert ensure top-notch
education simply learn job assist help
you to get notice by Leading companies
this program covers statistic python
supervised and unsupervised learning NLP
neural network computer vision Gans
Keras tensorflow and many more skills so
enroll now and unlock exciting Ai and ml
opportunities the link is in the
description box below
so without any further delay let's get
started some steps are crucial to master
in the field of AI and becoming an AI
engineer let's go through them real
quick first establish a strong
foundation in mathematics and
programming
start by gaining a solid understanding
of critical Concepts like lineal algebra
calculus and probability Theory
additionally it is crucial to become
proficient in programming language like
python which is commonly used in Ai and
developed coding skills
and the next one is pursue a degree in
relevant field on a bachelor or master
degree in computer science data science
or AI or related discipline to acquire
comprehensive understanding of AI
principles and techniques then acquire
knowledge in machine learning and deep
learning familiarize yourself with ML
algorithms neural networks and deep
learning Frameworks that is tensorflow
and Pi torch to train and optimize
models using real world data sets
afterwards engage in Practical projects
gain hands-on experience and demonstrate
your skills by working on AI projects
building a portfolio of projects that
showcase your ability to solve AI
problems can make a strong impression on
potential employers and the fifth one is
collaborate and network engage with
communities attend conferences and
participate in the online forums to
connect with the Professionals in the
field collaborating with others can
enhance your learning experience and
open up new opportunities and the sixth
one is seek internship or entry level
positions gain practical experience
through AI internship or entry level
roles in Industries or research
institutions this will provide valuable
exposure and help you further develop
your skill and at the last continuously
learning and adapt in the Fast Pace
world of EI it is crucial to stay
updated on new developments explore
specialized ideas and embrace emerging
Technologies and tools continuous
learning and adaptability are essential
for purchasing a successful career as a
AI engineer so now that you are familiar
with the steps involved in the Journey
of AI engineer let's have a look at the
salary of an AI engineer
so according to Glassdoor the average
reported salary of an AI engineer in the
United States is 105
000 per year however in India it is 10
lakh per annum
so these figures are way better than the
average salary figures of any job role
so let's discuss
the skills you need to become an AI
engineer you should have a strong
background in data science and machine
learning here is a breakdown of your
skills number one strong programming
abilities they typically refers to
expertise in one or more programming
languages commonly used in data science
and machine learning such as Python and
R Proficiency in programming allows you
to write efficient and scalable code for
data analysis modeling and algorithm
implantation and the second one is
knowledge of machine learning algorithms
this involves understanding and
familiarity with a wide range of machine
learning algorithm including both
supervised and unsupervised learning you
should be able to select and apply
appropriate algorithm for a specific
problem as well as evaluate and optimize
their performance
and the third one is Proficiency in
statistics and Mathematics sound
knowledge of statistics and Mathematics
is fundamental for data analysis and
machine learning you should be
comfortable with statical Concept
hypothesis testing regression analysis
probability Theory Lillian algebra and
calculus and the fourth one is
familiarity with deep learning
Frameworks deep learning has gained
significant popularity in recent years
and familiarity with deep learning
Frameworks like tensorflow Pi torch or
Keras is valuable these Frameworks
provide tools and libraries for building
training and deploying deep neural
networks for tasks such as image
recognition natural language processing
and time series analysis
and the fifth one is
experience with big data Technologies
dealing with large scale data set
requires knowledge of Big Data
Technologies such as Apache Hadoop or
Apache spark or distributed computing
Frameworks understanding how to process
store analyze data efficiently in
distributed environment and the sixth
one is excellent problem solving and
analytical skills these skills enable
you to break down complex problem
identify key factors and develop
effective Solutions
you should be Adept at critical thinking
troubleshooting and debugging to handle
real world challenges in the data
science and machine learning remember to
stay updated with the latest advancement
in the field and continuing learning to
stay at the Forefront of data science
and machine learning so that's all we
had for you in this video we can call it
a wrap now if you still have any
question or doubts let us know in the
comment section below our team of expert
will help you at the earliest thank you
so much for being here today we'll see
you next time until then stay safe and
keep learning with simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in Cutting Edge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing designed in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
thank you